[Music]
hi i'm gemma chan and i play cersei i'm
richard madden and i play icarus i'm
lauren ridloff and i play makari i'm
liam mchugh and i play sprite and i'm
kamel nanjiani and i play kingo in
marvel studios it turned out which
member of our cast is most likely to
stay up all night watching marvel's
studios movies
come on i would definitely say camille
he's already labeled himself as the
marvel geek i've seen all these movies
multiple times and i love watching
movies at night who would be most likely
to give the perfect take
what did you say did you say you
probably angelina she was always very
prepared yeah she's a pro probably me
and then andrew who's most likely to
laugh during a take i would probably say
selma she just laughs all throughout the
day most likely to nap on set
don or karoon
don don't
most likely to organize a hangout after
work oh i suppose we have to give that
to angie she threw us a amazing
halloween party she actually hosted
different gatherings for our family to
hang out together we went i'm kite
flying we had a halloween party a movie
night most likely to break into song and
dance it's going to be camille he's got
the dance number
[Music]
you